commitment commitment commitment
commitment commitment commitment
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can commit to one
thing fully and that is success
the road to success is through
commitment and through the strength to
drive through that commitment when it
gets hard and it is gonna get hard and
you're gonna want to quit sometimes but
it'll be colored by who you are
and more who you want to be I definitely
found that wanting to be an actor stems
from wanting to be somebody and wanting
to say something to people
commitment plays heavily in everything
if you made a commitment when you hit
the rough spots not if when you hit the
rough spots your immediate thought is
how can I solve the problem if you've
not made the commitment when you get the
rough spot whether it's in marriage or
education or career or whatever your
first thought is man how can I get out
of this deal and so that commit that
plays a huge role and is you know some
people are about as committed as a
kamikaze pilot on his 39th mission I
mean they don't really take it this
seriously I think in order to be an
artist you have to be committed beyond a
reasonable doubt if you to be a writer
you have to be committed beyond a
reasonable doubt that'll be this subtext
to the subtitle to the the talk today
committed beyond a reasonable doubt and
I think that when you take the road less
traveled you have to have that
commitment and I think that you know
people may go to some shows for a party
I think people come to our shows for
something else entirely
your excuse
I'm talking about
well Mike you over that's yesterday's
will be friendly and you
culture I want to highlight two main
problems with that old tired me first
approach to life first of all it
distracts you from what's truly
important and it may lead you to
compromise your values and your
principles and your commitments think
about it it's in chasing titles and
status in worrying about the next
election rather than the national
interest and the interests of those who
you're supposed to represent that
politicians so often lose their ways in
Washington they spend time thinking
about polls but not about principle it
was in pursuit of gaudy short-term
profits and the bonuses that came with
them that so many folks lost their way
on Wall Street engaging in extraordinary
risks with other people's money
in contrast the leaders we Revere the
businesses and institutions that last
they are not generally the result of a
narrow pursuit of popularity or personal
advancement but of devotion to some
bigger purpose
the preservation of the union or the
determination to lift a country out of a
depression the creation of a quality
product a commitment to your customers
your workers your shareholders and your
community a commitment to make sure that
an institution like ASU is inclusive and
diverse and giving opportunity to all
that's the hallmark of real success
basically I was an accident before I was
a musician like I was in you say that
basically I was an actor that was my
main thing I loved that thing I was in
loads of theater groups so like did that
at school all the time
and then I quickly realized like the
weird thing is like I can show you in 30
seconds how talented I am at music but I
can't show you in 30 seconds how
talented acting on and I realized like I
can't actually have a successful acting
career without having a good part first
and I just don't like auditions so yeah
for me I that there was a point where I
auditioned for this i TV show and it was
a music and acting and I thought this
will be fun and I got down to like the
final six and I said to myself if I get
this no more music just acting and if I
don't no more acting just music and I
didn't and then just did music and then
it kind of all went well but I've I've
always wanted to act but I didn't want
to do something for the sake of it
ayrton it has been a quite incredible
season for you you are the youngest ever
three times world champion three times
in four years I have to ask you on
behalf of your despairing rivals is your
motivation still as high as ever I think
so
I I am as you said young and healthy I
am as committed as ever to my passion to
our passion and to my profession and the
main thing is to find ways time after
time to stimulate myself in my own
ordering my own funny ways to dedicate a
lot of my time and a lot of my thinking
and keep up with the commitment that is
quite high to continue to be successful
if you think you can make a difference
it requires commitment it requires a
thick skin
it requires an inner compass that I
would recommend it you also as a sign to
be able to explain things at any level
yeah and not sound like you're being
condescending that doesn't work but but
having done that is some of the best
sciences I know can explain the science
truthfully and accurately at any level
from from the deepest experts to to
people who are not really scientists or
may not even have an interest in science
but to show them that you know why do we
think what it is how can that be useful
to society well you see this is your
third book I mean the first one was
anyone can do it the second one was wake
up and change your life how to be smart
with your money it kind of makes it
sound easy but it's it's not that easy
as it
everyone will be doing it it is easy
anybody could do it
there's not many people who doing do it
anyway and one can go and start a
business I mean you know a successful
business you know I was not educated I
like school at 15 I joined our Navy I
get worn out when I was 19 years old
spent six months in clink I spent a few
days but linearly along three years
where I couldn't go job I said business
because it couldn't go job and I'm about
29 - there's another 29 and I started a
business
I mean you study is well documented and
you've you know summarized are very well
there and it fascinates me I mean
basically up to 30 we were a bit of a
bond and I'll say that I know what I
mean we know what you mean
and then within seven years you were a
multi-millionaire what did you start
doing differently you must have started
to do something differently well I
started in business by selling ice cream
and then in what the opposition run and
I bought few more violence and I went
from there and then I decided that was
gonna be a national business me badk
Laura and the build a brand new nursing
home be single bedrooms
mr. solid everything I sold my house or
colored television my scream business my
car everything their mortgages a lot
more money in credit cards and you and
the National was open it but what's more
what it cost
noir have paid off on my desk that was
it I still think something was it
clicked in your head on it does it does
it help having nothing to lose
yes absolutely yes you say you need less
you sold that and but if you if you've
got a family already and you've got or
whatever these people has been brought
up to scrimp and save and you've got
lots of dependents then you've got too
much to lose to take the risk
yeah if you did the doctor or business
of life entrepreneurs successful
entrepreneur should see there was some
of had no education no best school well
I'm silly currently jobs as the couch in
socks
bank managers and 300,000 plan a year on
bankers and Sousa so they had no choice
either they stand business or they got a
job sweeping the streets or something
okay John thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I love to
know what you thought of the video I'd
love to know what your favorite clip is
from the video leave it in the comments
below and I will join in the discussion
I also wanted to give a quick shout out
today to Lily mom thank you so much Lily
she's an instructor also at journaled
and salsa
Lily bought two copies of my book for
your chance to get a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
and email in
receipt so we can keep track of you
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon